the West Coast drought is still in full
effect wildfires are raging throughout
California 18,000 people have lost their
jobs fields are laying fallow and wells
are running dry and as the state waives
its water priorities we wondered is all
water use created equal
after all one man's drinking water is
another's 18-hole golf course we headed
out to hear from both sides of one of
the worst droughts in US history and
where better to start than in Palm
Springs is a resort Wonderland that had
a heyday in Hollywood's golden era and
it was constructed in the middle of a
desert which seemed like a good idea at
the time
it's no wonder that residents here have
the highest water consumption in the
entire space it also has over a hundred
and twenty golf courses this one's
called the desert princess it's 300
acres of golf courses tennis courts
vacation homes lakes and pools
yeah there's pools everywhere there's a
pool there's a pool here there's a pool
right here everyone
Jonas Conlon the club superintendent
takes me on a tour there's a new
irrigation system being built and the
club has arranged a turf exchange deal
with the local water district they get
money to replace the grass we're getting
$15,000 per acre maximum seven acres so
$105,000 is a rebate that we'll get are
you going to Vegas with that money yeah
I wish
so was the incentive actually the
drought a little bit but not not 100%
but there was certainly that aspect a
lot of people not only here in Palm
Springs but here there's a princess
they're used to and comfortable with the
Country Club style that they have so
anytime you do a change where it's a
less water less color less grass people
get a little bit nervous yeah it's just
very visual
painful a lot of people that don't live
here or maybe not even live in
California when they come down here
their expectations are exactly what it
was before move on a green we want to
play we want to be happy being happy
that's not a crime is it Raphael sir my
lives in East Porterville in Tulare
County five hours north of luscious Palm
Springs it's ground zero for the
California drought golfers are people
too have you ever been golfing should
you try it first before you knock it I
think this know the self eNOS of the
people right now in this in this in this
situation is I don't care as long as I
have I don't rest here in the Central
Valley many residents rely on private
wells last June sir my I became one of
5,000 without running water when his
well went dry so this was your well that
was my work now it's totally dead
there's no water coming out the only way
is if we were like a hundred twenty feet
I can't afford to go deeper than this
even not 90 feet deep is between 12 of
25 25 thousand dollars after months of
waiting and lobbying local officials
Raphael his family and neighbors now get
potable water from the county and a
water tank arranged by the drought
service organization self help
enterprises we have this water tank over
here for two families this is a little
house and the next four was and have six
of them what are your thoughts on the
future I feel a little bit nervous
because if we don't don't don't preserve
water what's gonna happen later for a
for our our children's I love the one
area where there's a trickle of water
you see that's a little the face of the
size dry and you have a little mini
Oasis here meiosis you have like to
start up a golf course just right here
yeah we know where to find one yeah
do you think it's fair that more water
is being put into golf courses and a
sport that is so boring it's a small
portion compared to things like farming
things like municipalities what about
just painting the whole thing if it was
a little bit more enticing to where we
could put the paint out and and still
get the results and save money and have
it look good that would be a little bit
better selling money thing it can be
money in the end of the day everyone's
just trying to make do with the drought
some are just making out a whole lot
better